وهذه مشاهدينا الصور مباشره للحرم القدسي
حيث يبدو الهدوء يوم المكان عقب التوترات
الامنيه الكبيره منذ ليله البارحه التي
تشهدها الاراضي الفلسطينيه اذ اقتحمت كما
ذكرنا قوات اسرائيليه فجر هذا اليوم حاد
المسجد الاقصى وحشمت بعض النوافذ والقت
ايضا قنابل صوتيه لاجبار المعتكفين داخل
المسجد على المغادره عمليه الاقتحام هذه
مشاهدينا بحسب هيئه شؤون الاسرى
يعني تسببت في اعتقال نحو 500 معتك بينما
قالت الشرطه الاسرائيليه انها اوقفت 300
شخصا
مشاهدينا الان تنضموا الينا من القدس
مراسل العربيه
تماما امام او في بحاد المسجد الاقصى هل
هو هدوء ما قبل العاصفه من الاوضاع ستستمر
في هذا الوضع بحسب الاجراءات الامنيه
المتخذه من قبل الاسرائيلي لنا
اهلا بك احمد صحيح يعني منذ ساعات الصباح
الباكر في تمام الساعه السابعه في توقيت
القدس كان هناك اقتحام من قبل مجموعتين من
المستوطنين وايضا اليهود قاموا باقتحام
الساحات المسجد الاقصى بحمايه اعداد كبيره
من القوات الاسرائيليه ولكن الان كان هناك
يعني هدوء دعنا نصفه بانه هدوء يعني حذر
فعليا داخل ساحات المسجد الاقصى بعد
اقتحام اعداد كبيره ايضا من اليهود ساحات
المسجد الاقصى قاموا بالدخول من باب
المغاربه
والتجول في ساحات المسجد الاقصى وخروجا من
باب السلسله في ظل هذه
الاجواء كان هناك ايضا تواجد لعدد من
الفلسطينيين داخل المسجد الاقصى يحاولون
يعني الصد لهذه الاقتحامات ولكن القوات
الاسرائيليه قامت باعتقال ايضا عدد منهم
صباح اليوم واخ عدد اخر من الفلسطينيين من
من ساحات المسجد الاقصى كان هناك ايضا
اعتداء على سيده فلسطينيه من داخل المسجد
الاقصى دعنا نصف بان هذا التوتر مازال
موجودا وهناك حاله تاهب ايضا في البلده
القديمه في القدس وانتشار كبير للقوات
الاسرائيليه يعني تاهبا لزياد التوتر
فعليا بعد ان شاهدنا عشر ايام هادئه من
رمضان في القدس والمسجد الاقصى المبارك
طيب لنا من نشاهدهم في هذه الصور انهم
فلسطينيون اليس كذلك يعني هل سمحت سلطه
الاسرائيليه للفلسطينيين بالعوده الى
زياره المسجد الاقصى بشكل طبيعي
عفوا هل سمحت لهم ماذا يعني نشاهد في
الصور على ما يبدو انه فلسطينيون في هذه
الصور
زوار للمسجد الاقصى هل يعني ذلك ان
السلطات الاسرائيليه سمحت لبعضهم بالعوده
للصلاه وزياره المسجد الاقصى والحرم
القدسي بعد هذه العمليه التي تجار الصباح
اليوم
صحيح كان هناك عوده كالمعتاد للصلاه من
قبل الفلسطينيين
والمقدسيين للصلاه في المسجد الاقصى بعد
ان قامت ايضا باعتقال اكثر من 400 فلسطيني
ليله امس وقامت ايضا باخراج عدد منهم ولكن
اعداد كبيره تم اخراجهم بشروط الابعاد
لاسابيع او اسبوع على الاقل من البلده
القديمه او حتى منع الدخول للمسجد الاقصى
وايضا غرامات ماليه ايضا قبل قليل كان
هناك اعتقال لاحد المستوطنين او ايقاف
فعليا حاول الدخول الى البلده القديمه
وكان يحمل القرابين وكان هناك ايضا محاوله
ودعوات من قبل المستوطنين بوجود مكافات
لمن يستطيع الدخول الى المسجد الاقصى وذبح
ما يعرف بالقرابين اليهوديه بسبب الاعياد
اليهوديه هل من دعوات الاحتجاج والتصعيد
رصدت في المناطق الفلسطينيه او في القدس
تحديدا
ضد حدث خلال صباح هذا اليوم لنا
صحيح هناك دعوات حتى من الداخل الفلسطيني
واراضي ال 48 هناك دعوات كبيره من
الفلسطينيين للذهاب الى المسجد الاقصى
والاعتكاف في المسجد الاقصى ردا على
الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه هناك ايضا دعوات
لاحتجاجات وايضا الاشتباك مع القوات
الاسرائيليه على اعداد كبيره من الحواجز
كان هناك ايضا قبل قليل اطلاق النار على
احد الحواجز الاسرائيليه في مدينه بيت لحم
التي تفصل بين الضفه الغربيه واراضي 48
والقدس نحن نتحدث عن يعني بدء حاله التوتر
بشكل كبير وهناك يعني احتمال كبير بان
تتفجر الاوضاع وتخرج عن السيطره خاصه بان
ايضا هناك دعوات منه وزير الامن القومي
اعتمر بنجفير بالذهاب
وذهاب المستوطنين واقتحامهم للمسجد الاقصى
وهناك ايضا مطالبات من بنك فير بالرد بشكل
كبير على الفصائل الفلسطينيه في قط اع غزه
وايضا يقول بان اطلاق الصواريخ في مناطق
مفتوحه ضد فصائل الفلسطينيه في قطاع غزه
هو امر غير كافي ويجب الرد بشكل قاسي